faim, vous achetez un oncle Sam, c'est mr.
président, nous sommes à un moment de cette guerre
qui est le plus dangereux pour les
plus grandes réalisations historiques connues de
l'homme,
les nazis ont volé des œuvres d'art à
Varsovie Amsterdam Paris et pour constituer une équipe, nous
n'avons pas essayé de protéger ce qui
restait, une amende était  il manque les monuments
hommes signés par Roosevelt combien d'hommes pour
l'instant six chef bien avec vous à sept
que vous êtes seul pour ça oui vous avez
tous été sélectionnés parce que nous aurons
besoin de vos connaissances nous aurons besoin de
vos compétences, réfléchissez bien  sergent de guerre,
[ __ ], nous avons suivi une
formation de base de base en Angleterre, oh mon Dieu, sympa, ici,
nous avons été chargés de trouver et de
protéger plus de cinq millions d'
œuvres d'art volées, c'est un modèle de son
plan, la peur de l'utilisation, Ian, ce sera un  des
plus grands au monde et beaucoup d'art pour
le remplir, c'est pourquoi Hitler n'a pas bombardé
Paris, il a bombardé Londres oui, je sais
Kenneth, tu n'auras pas l'
équipement, tu n'auras pas la
main-d'œuvre, je pense que  ça s'est bien passé les
nazis sont en fuite ils emportent
tout avec eux donc il faut se rapprocher
le plus possible du front
je suis intéressé par ce que tu as vu là
des milliers de pièces ils
photographieraient les artistes pour
les faire nous  vous allez devoir devancer
la Troisième Armée et entrer en Allemagne. Comment puis-
je vous aider à voler nos œuvres d'art volées ? Vous
pouvez anéantir toute une génération. Vous
pouvez incendier leurs maisons et, d'
une manière ou d'une autre, ils retrouveront toujours leur chemin,
mais  si vous détruisez leur histoire,
vous détruisez leurs réalisations et c'est
qu'ils n'ont jamais existé c'est ce que
veut Hitler c'est exactement pour cela que
nous nous battons
[Musique]
c'est une directive signée par Hitler qui
dit que s'il meurt ou si l'Allemagne tombe
là-bas  détruis tout
ça n'est pas arrêté j'ai l'impression d'avoir marché
sur une mine pourquoi as-tu fait quelque chose
comme ce
bon lieutenant ici semble
s'être retrouvé sur une mine non explosée
pourquoi ferais-tu ça tu passes
trop de temps ensemble
toi